we are going to have to think about the
fact that over the last week week and a
bit we have sort of been learning how to
use a variety of different tools in the
topic of what topic is it probability
thank you so being understanding the
chances of different things happening I
know thank you and probability is the
field of mathematics that helps us to
understand that now I want you to put
yourself in the position of being like
someone who is I was going to use the
phrase handyman but your handy person
you know you're someone who's really
good at fixing things
then you don't just know how to use a
particular tool you also have the skill
of knowing when is the right time to use
one tool or another now bless you so far
we've had a look at a couple of big
concepts and a couple of different
visual tools and then what we did was we
would say oh here's a visual tool for
you and then now I'm going to give you
an exercise that lets you use that tool
over and over again okay what we're
going to do now is a little different
I'm going to give you a series of
problems and it's going to be up to you
to work out what is the appropriate tool
to use in this situation it won't be
immediately obvious and that's why I
want us to make the heading of
probability overview I want us to very
rapidly and only one spend about five
minutes on this very rapidly rehearse
what are they and therefore what are the
two big ideas and two different visual
tools that we've learned over the last
little bit that help us understand
probabilities so I know number them one
two three and four
firstly when we think about probability
right number one because we've talked
about probability over and over again we
stopped writing the word because um it's
it's a waste of time we're like we know
that the letter P the capital letter P
we're just going to use that to indicate
probability if you want to work out the
probability of some kind of event then
we state all probabilities as a number
between 0 and 1 and you can't have 0 1
if you had an event with a probably of
zero what would that mean
never gonna happen you had an event that
had probability of 1 it would mean
100% certainty is definitely without a
shadow of a doubt going to happen so our
probabilities always lie between zero
and one they are a fraction what goes on
the top on the numerator of our fraction
maybe yeah okay yes it is called the
numerator can someone tell me and this
is what is the numerators number of
favorable outcomes thank you can we all
write that down just as a news said so
these are the outcomes that we're
interested in the favorable outcomes the
outcomes that make that event take place
okay that's on the top of my very long
and awkward fraction and they can
someone help me work out what's on the
denominator Jessica okay the number of
outcomes in the sample space or if you
like to write it in a way that is sort
of parallel to this you could say the
number of possible outcomes that's
another way to describe how big is the
sample space so the key words are
favorable and possible right one of the
ones you're interested in and then what
can actually take place what is possible
like on a die you've got one two three
four five six those are the possible
outcomes okay so that was the first big
idea the second big idea was we said you
know some events can combine together
with others they're kind of like two
sides of the same coin and we call that
a word starting with seeds and remember
the complement thank you and we
remembered it's a bit tricky you spelled
a couple of not with an i but with an e
thank you otherwise you're just saying
hey you did a great job right now the
complement we would say if you've got
some event E then the complement we
would write as an e with a bar over the
top or you can just say not E or you
could name what the complement was if I
said okay the probability of an event
I'm interested in might be rolling a six
on a die what would that probability be
by the way why not a six very good so
I'm actually going to jot that down at
the top here the probability of rolling
a six would be one out of six there's
only one favorable outcome on the die
and there are six possible
I could say the compliment of that right
the probability of the continent I could
just name what are all of the other
things that could happen what what are
all the other things that can happen
apart from a six yeah one all through
five right one two three four five one
two three four five what is that
probability by the way fail oh six is
five different possible outcomes sorry
five different favorable outcomes and
it's still the same six that are
possible now the way we wrote that
noticing that these two probabilities
are not just random they're connected
what do they add up to they add up to
one cuz they're all the possible
outcomes right so we could say that the
probability of an event plus the
probability of its complement
that's equal to one right and we notice
we could use that fact if you wanted to
know the probability of an event you can
actually work out the opposite of that
which sometimes easier and subtract that
from one so we had a look at that last
week as well now to round this out there
were then two visual tools that we use
to help us understand different
situations in probability they both
require us to draw draw some diagrams
does anyone remember what the first kind
of diagram was was named after a guy
Venn diagrams very good then diagrams
when do we use Venn diagrams when are
they particularly useful what do you do
when there are two things that are
overlapping exactly right so maybe in
fact we might just draw a very small
Vindhya Graham here just to give us a
visual cue so as Richard said that's
perfect there you go two things that are
overlapping sometimes you could even
have more but we just stayed at this
level of complexity then there was one
other kind of theme ever used vishakha
to wait tables fantastic so these also
are helpful when you're understanding
some different groups or categories that
sometimes and it depends on the
situation a table is a much easier way
to illustrate all the numbers and
generally they looked something like
this
whoops I need another row that's better
and then we would describe you know like
say boys and girls you know brown eyes
blue eyes things like that and
these were the main tools that we use to
visualize okay